cudzoziemcy w polskiej policji
komenda główna policji
analizuje właśnie możliwość zmiany przepisów
aby dopuścić ukraińców
białorusinów i gruzinów do służby w polskiej policji
co to Nam gwarantuje
gwarantuje Nam to inwigilacje i ingerencje obcych
w nasz wewnętrzny układ
w nasze bezpieczeństwo
statystyki są nieubłagane
to gruzini procentowo
popełniają największą
ilość przestępstw wszystkich mniejszości narodowych
z kolei ukraińców jest już tak dużo
że w liczbach bezwzględnych przodują w statystykach
z kolei Białoruś
prowadzi przecież OD lat z polską wojnę hybrydową
i dobrze wiemy
że najpierw zależało im na sforcowaniu granicy
a gdy powstał mur
to to jest Po prostu prezent dla łukaszenki
aby białorusini mogli inwigilować polskie służby
nie ma podwójnej lojalności wobec 2 różnych państw
dlatego konfederacja mówi jasno
stop imigrantom
stop obcokrajowcom w polskich służbach mundurowych